meanwhile the senate democrats continue
to
push forward with doing nothing so their
campaign is the same as the as the biden
campaign at this point and that is do
nothing
until donald trump is out of the white
house so amy coney barrett is moving
forward toward a vote senate judiciary
democrats say they're going to
boycott today's vote on amy coney
barrett they put out a statement they
say this has been a sham process from
the beginning
weird since you all participated in the
judicial confirmation hearing
they say amidst a global pandemic an
ongoing election republicans are rushing
to confirm a supreme court justice to
take away health care from millions and
execute the extreme and deeply unpopular
agenda they've been unable to get
through congress
republicans broke the promises they made
and the rules they created
when they blocked merrick garland's
nomination for eight months under under
president obama
then senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell said the american people
should have a voice in the selection of
their next supreme court justice now
republicans have moved at breakneck
speed to jam through this nominee
ignoring her troubling record and
unprecedented evasions and breaking
long-standing committee rules to set
tomorrow's vote
okay that no no no no no no
when the party of the president and the
party of the senate are not the same
senators rarely vote for the nominees of
the president of the united states in an
election year
that just does not happen all that often
by the way i love that they are saying
that amy coney barrett has a troubling
record they literally caught her on
nothing
they caught her out on nothing and they
say unprecedented evasions oh you mean
her use of the ginsburg rule established
by one joe biden
on behalf of one ruth bader ginsburg
sure sure
so democrats say that they are not going
to grant this process any further
legitimacy by participating in a
committee markup of this nomination
just 12 days before the culmination of
an election that is already underway
okay fine tough catch you later
so they are they are not participating
in the judicial vote
tough tough again their whole philosophy
of the judiciary is completely perverse
erwin tremorinsky who is a first
amendment
law professor at university of
california berkeley has an entire piece
explaining why the left hates amy coney
barrett so much he says her philosophy
makes her incredibly dangerous why do we
really want our rights to be determined
by the understandings of centuries ago
well you can determine your rights to
the ballot box
the the fact that the supreme court of
the united states is tasked with
interpreting a document
to mean what it meant that is not a
violation of rights it is a violation of
rights to have a bunch of people like
erwin trumarinsky sitting above you
and deciding for you what your rights
are trevorinsky says originalists
believe the meaning of a constitutional
provision is fixed when it was adopted
it can be changed only by constitutional
amendment yep
under the under this view the first
amendment means the same thing as it was
as it
did when it was adopted in 1791 and the
14th amendment means the same thing as
when it was ratified in 1868
yes because that's how law works
typically law doesn't magically change
and morph
based on circumstance the law means what
it meant if i heard a letter to my wife
today it speaks of my feelings for my
wife today
right it does not change it does not
morph it is not poetry
okay when you write that is the purpose
of written language literally the
purpose of written language is to codify
what people are thinking
right then you wouldn't read a book by
dostoyevsky
and then try to interpret it as a racial
parable about america in 2020.
okay because dostoevsky wasn't writing
about that that's silly
okay but this is the silly
constitutional perspective of the left
tremorinsky says rights in the 21st
century should not be determined by the
understandings and views of centuries
ago
that would lead to terrible results the
same congress that voted to ratify the
14th amendment which assures equal
protection of the laws
also voted to segregate the district of
columbia public schools
following originalism would mean that
brown versus board of education was
wrongly decided in declaring laws
requiring segregation of schools
unconstitutional okay well let's play
that out
let's say for a second that the court
had not ruled the way that it did in
brown vs board of education
you know what would have happened the
civil rights act of 1964.
in fact it might have happened earlier
okay because as gerald rosenberg writes
in the hollow hope it is very rare that
the supreme court is a leader in any
capacity usually they simply follow the
legislature
or state legislatures and they simply
forecast a little bit ahead
the attempt to override the rule of law
in favor of results that you want is
incredibly incredibly dangerous but that
is of course what democrats want
from the court the good news is they
won't get it so they are boycotting the
amy coney barrett vote well
tough noogies who cares that doesn't
that doesn't matter this thing is going
through
meanwhile senate democrats have decided
to block another attempt to provide
relief to the american people
thanks to covet lockdowns according to
cnbc
senate democrats blocked republicans
attempts to pass a 500 billion
corona virus stimulus bill on wednesday
as house speaker nancy pelosi and
treasury secretary steve mnuchin make a
last-ditch
push to strike a relief deal before the
2020 election
now mitch mcconnell has been telling
trump not to go along with those
negotiations why
because mcconnell knows how this works
usually what happens the mnuchin gets in
a room with pelosi he immediately gives
away the entire store
trump signs off on it and then it turns
out to be difficult to wrangle the votes
in the senate for a bad deal
so instead what you're saying is how
about this how about we pass what we
want to pass since we are the party of
the majority
in the senate and uh and then you just
stand by that
and then nancy pelosi is the
obstructionist that is mitch mcconnell's
position it happens to be
the correct position senate democrats
did obstruct yesterday they once again
filibustered a vote
that had majority approval if the
measure
failed in a 51-44 party-line vote it
required 60 votes to shut down the
filibuster
the stalemate in the senate extends
months of gridlock on capitol hill as
millions of americans trying to afford
food and housing and keep their
businesses open
await more federal aid during an
economic crisis election year politics
have jarred the legislative process
as new coven-19 infections reach levels
unseen in weeks republicans in congress
argue that democrats have reached for an
expensive wish list filled with many
provisions
unrelated to the crisis mcconnell has
said the
democrats are engaging in all or nothing
obstruction as they hold out for a
comprehensive deal worth about
two trillion dollars it's the federal
government between the federal reserve
and the money that has already been
allocated by congress we've spent
something like
to seven trillion dollars so far
democrats wants another two
trillion dollars not a narrow relief
package tailored to helping people in
the now they want to bail out states for
all of their bad union contracts
going back years they want a bunch of
unrelated provisions stacked into a
giant pork bill
democrats meanwhile say that the bill is
quote unquote partisan
and emaciated the legislation before the
senate on wednesday included funds for a
second paycheck protection program loan
for struggling small businesses
a 300 per week supplemental unemployment
insurance benefit and liability
protections for businesses among other
provisions
it didn't include another round of
direct payments to people instead it was
designed to get
businesses up and running again both
pelosi and mark meadows said they aim to
have a deal in place before the end
of the week but of course every time the
white house takes a step toward the
democrats position
they risk losing republican support and
it is unlikely that mcconnell is going
to bring
forth a bill that does not have at least
a majority of republicans
in support of the bill so democrats
continue to obstruct
coveted relief that is no shock they
have very little interest in the needs
of the american people this is all about
electioneering
at this point did you know that every
like on this video creates one
additional leftist tier don't ask me why
that's called science to take advantage
of this amazing opportunity
hit the like button